hi herzlich Willkommen bei uns bei ZDF
heute live schön dass ihr bei uns im
Stream seid es war eine der größten
razien in der Geschichte der
Bundesregierung und der Bundesrepublik
etwa 3000 Spezialkräften gelingt am
Morgen ein Schlag gegen 25 Personen aus
dem sogenannten reichsbürgermilieu sie
wurden jetzt wegen Terrorverdachts auch
festgenommen weil sie offenbar den
Bundestag stürmen wollten und den
deutschen Staat durch eine eigene
Staatsform ersetzen wollten laut
Bundesanwaltschaft sein die Pläne der
Vereinigung dazu auch ziemlich konkret
gewesen gleich um 14 Uhr wird sich der
Generalbundesanwalt auf einer
Pressekonferenz zu den ersten
Erkenntnissen äußern und die
Pressekonferenz die streamen wir
natürlich live für euch hier vorher
sprechen wir aber über die ersten
gesicherten Informationen auch über die
Dimension mit unserer ZDF Rechtsexpertin
Sarah Tacke und mit den dahinter
steckenden Plänen da werden wir
Einordnung schaffen mit dem
Rechtsextremismus Experten mir Dietrich
was beschäftigt euch dazu alle Fragen
alle Kommentare gerne entweder direkt in
die Chats oder hier per Mail einen
Adresse wird eingeblendet hätte erfreute
- live at zdf.de so wie versprochen wir
ordnen ein was wir bisher wissen und was
nicht vor der Pressekonferenz des
Generalbundesanwalts das machen wir mit
ZDF Rechtsexpertin sarattacke hallo
erstmal Sarah grüß Dich danke für deine
Zeit
gern hallo Sarah lass uns gerne den
aktuellen Stand zusammenfassen was
wissen wir über diese Razzia und auch
über die Köpfe die dahinter stecken
genau klar ist dass der
Generalbundesanwalt hier aus Karlsruhe
die Ermittlung geführt hat und auch die
Festnahmen koordiniert hat klar ist auch
das ist sehr viele Festnahmen gab es
sollen auch bereits die ersten
festgenommen mutmaßlichen Terroristen
den Ermittlungsrichter hier am
Bundesgerichtshof in Karlsruhe
vorgeführt worden sein weitere werden
folgen es sind ja zahlreiche Festnahmen
und Glas auch die Motivlage wir haben es
hier mit mutmaßlichen inländischen
Terroristen zu tun die sich vor ca einem
Jahr zusammengeschlossen haben sie
sollen deutschlandweit sich vernetzt
haben Deutschland als vernetzt sein und
vor allem und das macht es soweit in den
Sicherheitsbehörden vernetzt sein es
sollen ehemalige Soldaten darunter sein
auch eine aktiver es sollen Polizisten
darunter sein eine Richterin ehemalige
afd-politiker das zeigt wie breit dieses
Netzwerk ist aber auch wie gut vernetzt
es ist und das macht die Gefährlichkeit
aus zudem soll das Netzwerk bereit
gewesen sein und billigend in Kauf
genommen haben für den Umsturz den Sie
geplant haben auch Menschen im Zweifel
zu töten ihn soll bewusst gewesen sein
dass einem Umsturz die amtierende
Bundesregierung abzulösen ein
staatsstreif auch im Zweifel nur mit
Gewalt möglich sein und auch dazu sollen
sie bereit gewesen sein die
Vorbereitungen sollen sogar soweit
gewesen sein dass es bald Schießübungen
gab das Waffen da waren weitere Details
werden wir hier aber um 14 Uhr in der
Pressekonferenz erfahren es ist ein
Statement des Generalbundesanwalts
geplant keine Fragen zugelassen und da
wollen wir dann hoffentlich auch hören
wieso jetzt auch der Zugriff erfolgt ist
und 3000 Polizisten sind gegen diese
Pläne gegen diese Umsturzpläne von denen
du sprichst heute morgen vorgegangen
seit 6 Uhr sie haben in 11 Bundesländern
in Deutschland Untersuchungen geführt
und auch Länder übergreifend in
Österreich und Italien daran was sagt
das aus über die Dimension dieser Razzia
und auch dieser Pläne die uns heute da
präsentiert werden
jetzt klingt ja beim ersten Hinhören
verrückt dass da Menschen sich
zusammengeschlossen haben um einen
Staatsstreich geplant haben und das soll
sogar so sein dass sie bereits
Ministerposten unter sich aufgeteilt
haben soll die festgenommene Richterin
beispielsweise hätte Justizminister
werden sollen ein weiterer
festgenommener Kopf des Ganzen ein
adliger sollte das neue Staatsoberhaupt
werden das klingt verrückt aber
diese mutmaßlichen Terroristen die da
festgenommen worden sind eben sehr gut
vernetzt Bundeswehr
polizeijustiz und das zeigt auch ihre
besondere Gefährlichkeit deshalb ist es
durchaus ernst zu nehmen und deshalb ist
die Polizei sind die Sicherheitskräfte
da heute auch mit dieser großangelegten
konstantierten abgesprochenen Aktion
vorgegangen
vielen Dank sarattacke für diese ersten
gesicherten Informationen zur
großangelegten Razzia heute gegen
Personen aus dem Reichsbürger Milieu wir
sprechen später weiter im Stream danke
für den Moment schauen jetzt aber
gemeinsam noch mal mit Isabel de la Vega
für uns auf die Entwicklungen und die
ersten Bilder des Morgens von dieser
Razzia
er soll der Kopf einer terroristischen
Vereinigung sein die laut
Bundesanwaltschaft einen
regierungsumsturz in Deutschland plante
ein adliger aus Frankfurt der der
reichsbürgerszene zugeordnet wird es ist
eine von 25 Festnahmen die heute früh in
ganz Deutschland stattfanden über 3000
spezialkräfte der Polizei und des BKA
durchsuchten 130 Objekte in mehreren
Bundesländern die Terrorvereinigung soll
seit über einem Jahr Pläne für einen
Sturz der Regierung geschmiedet haben
laut Generalbundesanwaltschaft sollen
neben einem Bundeswehrsoldaten und
mehreren Reservisten auch Querdenker und
Verschwörungstheoretiker Teil der
Terrorgruppe sein
bundesinnenministerin nennt sie Feser
spricht von Ermittlungen die Zitat in
den Abgrund einer terroristischen
Bedrohung aus dem Reichsbürger Milieu
blicken ließen doch die Gruppierung
greift über das reichsbürgermilie hinaus
heute morgen wurde in Berlin die
Richterin Birgit malsack Winkelmann
festgenommen die zuvor AFD Abgeordnete
im Bunde Tag war
soweit Isabel de lavega über die
aktuellen Informationen von heute morgen
und auch die Bilder bevor wir rüber
gehen zum Statement des
Generalbundesanwalts dr Peter Frank
begrüße ich jetzt schon einmal Herrn
Dietrich bei uns im Stream da haben wir
gerade noch die Bilder von dem Statement
wo es gleich sozusagen der
Generalbundesanwalt Platz dem wird jetzt
können wir aber sprechen mit Herrn
Dietrich von cemas
rechtsextremismusexperte herzlich
Willkommen bei uns danke für Ihre Zeit
guten Tag auch an sie noch mal die Frage
vor dem Statement vor den ersten
Erkenntnissen wie ordnen Sie die
Dimension des ganzen heute ein also wir
haben mit einem der größten Rationen
gegen eine terroristische Vereinigung zu
tun der deutschen Geschichte das ist
sehr sehr große Auswahl
beunruhigend ist vor allem dabei die
eben auch schon genannt die Verbindungen
in sicherheitsmilieu das heißt dass wir
das nicht nur mit ein paar wahren Leuten
in Deutschland zu tun haben sondern auch
Menschen die durchaus vom Staat selbst
eine Waffe ausgebildet wurden macht die
Pläne natürlich etwas kon später und
deutlich gefährlicher als einfach nur
ein paar Leute die auf Telegramm irre
Erzählungen verbreiten sagt schon mal
Miro Dietrich
rechtsextremismusforscher von cemas hier
bei uns wir warten immer noch auf das
Statement deswegen gibt uns das die
Chance Herr Dietrich weiter zu sprechen
und auch die erste user-frage von Chris
Watts vielleicht reinzunehmen er geht so
ein bisschen in die Richtung der Begriff
Reichsbürger in dem ganzen Prozess was
wir hier hören ist für ihn nicht
wirklich gut definiert wie vielen
verschiedenen Gruppen das ist seine
Frage sind da heute festgenommen worden
und auch festen Personen zuzuordnen und
die zweite Frage Vernetzung sind die
alle miteinander vernetzt
prinzipiell ist der Begriff Reichsbürger
etwas frei unter dem finden sich in
Deutschland sehr viele unterschiedliche
Phänomene man könnte das auch unter dem
Begriff souveränismus wohl besser fassen
was diese Bewegung auf jeden Fall eint
es scheint Erzählungen über die Idee
dass Deutschland kein souveräner Staat
wäre sondern dass Deutschland weiterhin
noch besetzt wäre
und einen zweiten Aspekt den wir uns
auch gemeinsam vielleicht jetzt hier bei
mir auf dem Laptop anschauen können
Stefan Niggemeier bei Twitter sagt geht
auf den Aspekt ein dass ungefähr jede
größere Redaktion vorab von dieser
gefährlichen Razzia wusste ähm am Morgen
auch eigene hintergrundstücke
veröffentlicht hat und er sagt aus
lesersicht praktisch aber für den
Fahndungserfolg vielleicht doch
problematisch Frage die ich gerne an SIE
weiterleite Herr Dietrich natürlich sehr
wichtig dass wenn diese Aktien
stattfinden dass die Leute nicht davor
gewarnt sind und sie eventuelle Waffen
oder weitere Beweise zu verstecken
tatsächlich wussten viele Leute
anscheinend von dieser Bescheid ob das
wirklich sein Problem entwickelt muss
man natürlich jetzt sehen wie die Ärztin
abgelaufen sind wie viel Material dort
gefunden wurde oder ob man irgendwie
nachweisen konnte dass ihr eine
Vorwarnung stattgefunden hat und
Material beiseite geschaffen wurde aber
da gibt's jetzt noch keine gesicherten
Informationen erstmal drüber richtig
aktuell stand nicht
dann bleiben wir bei dem was wir wissen
und was wir nicht wissen
Herr Dietrich was ist darüber hinaus wir
haben schon den mutmaßlichen Kopf der
Bewegung Prinz Reus gerade den Beitrag
gesehen was ist darüber hinaus über die
Personen und auch über die Verdrahtungen
innerhalb dieses Milieus bekannt
wir wissen dass sie aus
unterschiedlichen Spektrum kommen wie
eben schon genannt aus Polizei aus
Justiz aus dem Militär
ein weiterer Kopf der Bewegung der
angebliche Hauptverwaltung Rüdiger Fee
war ex-obers Leutnant wurde aus der
Bundeswehr entlassen weil er Waffen aus
der Nationalen Volksarmee für untreut
hat und verkauft hat er soll den
militärischen Flügel aufgebaut haben und
er war auch aktiv bei der Corona
Protestbewegung was wir sonst wissen ist
dass viele der Leute sich tatsächlich
auch in der Öffentlichkeit schon sehr
deutlich positioniert haben und ihre
verschwörungserzählungen
breit erzählt hatten also es waren jetzt
keine Unbekannten Leute die hier
festgenommen sind über die Details von
all diesen Leuten fehlen natürlich noch
ein bisschen Informationen aber über die
Kerngruppe weiß man zumindest dass das
jetzt ähm keine kleines Team Leute waren
die ihre Einstellung groß verborgen
haben
Dietrich sie sprechen gerade an dass die
Personen bereits öffentlich bekannt
geworden sind wir können jetzt auch auf
Statements hier noch mal bei mir schauen
auch aus der Bundesregierung die sich am
Morgen geäußert hat zumindest
Bundesjustizminister Marco Buschmann er
schrieb bei Twitter Demokratie ist
wehrhaft seit heute morgen findet ein
großer Anti terror-einsatz statt der
Generalbundesanwalt ermittelt gegen ein
mutmaßliches Terror Netzwerk aus dem
Reichsbürger Milieu es besteht der
Verdacht dass ein bewaffneter Überfall
auf Verfassungsorgane geplant war jetzt
sagen sie aber gerade die Personen die
festgenommen worden sind vorher schon
bekannt die Szene auch bekannt gewesen
hat die Regierung hat die Politik dieses
Szene und diese Leute da vorher auch zu
lange wuchern lassen
auf jeden Fall hier wurde ganz klar die
Gefahr dieser verschwörungsideologen
nicht ernst genommen
und
man muss ja sagen es ist ja die
unterbreche ich unterbreche nicht nicht
gern es tut mir leid aber wir hören
jetzt in das Statement vom
Generalbundesanwalt rein
wohnen in Deutschland in Österreich und
Italien festnehmen lassen wir werfen den
Festgenommenen Mitgliedschaft
oder Unterstützung einer inländischen
terroristischen Vereinigung vor diese
Vereinigung hat sich nach unseren
Erkenntnissen Ende November 2021 um den
Beschuldigten Heinrich h Punkt R Punkt
gebildet
die Vereinigung hat sich nach unseren
Erkenntnissen zum Ziel gesetzt die
bestehende staatliche Ordnung in
Deutschland die freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung und der
Einsatz von Gewalt und militärischen
Mitteln zu beseitigen
die Festgenommen verbindet die Ablehnung
der staatlichen Institutionen in
Deutschland
die Festgenommenen hängen
verschwörungsmythen an
bestehend aus verschiedenen narrativen
der reichsbürgerideologie sowie der
qn-ideologie
die
Vereinigung ist aus unseren nach unserer
Erkenntnis aufgebaut zunächst in einen
Art Rat die soll eine Art
Regierungsorganisation sein oder
regierungsteil sein der sich unterteilt
hat und gegliedert hat in verschiedene
Ressorts wie das Kabinett einer
Regierung eines Staates bereits einzelne
Personen waren vorgesehen für die
Übernahme einzelne Ressorts darunter für
das justizresort eine ehemalige
Abgeordnete des Deutschen Bundestages
neben diesem Rat der eine neue
Staatlichkeit und eine neue
Staatsstruktur planen sollte
besteht nach unserer Erkenntnis ein
militärischer Arm dieser militärische
Arm soll eine neue deutsche Armee
aufbauen
und bestehend aus noch neu zu gründen
Heimatschutz Kompanien
einzelne Mitglieder dieses militärischen
Armes war nach unserer Erkenntnis in der
Vergangenheit auch aktiv in der
Bundeswehr tätig
einzelne Mitglieder der terroristischen
Vereinigung haben sich nach unserer
Erkenntnis auch mit Überlegungen
getragen
gewaltsam in den Deutschen Bundestag
einzudringen
wir haben heute neben diesen Festnahmen
etwa 150 Durchsuchungen in 11
Bundesländern durchgeführt dabei wurde
umfangreiches Material sichergestellt
wir haben heute oder heute werden und
auch morgen nein heute und morgen werden
und wurden bereits die Festgenommenen
den ermittlungsrichtern des
Bundesgerichtshofs vorgeführt werden bei
8 der festgenommen darunter auch dem aus
unserer Sicht der regelführerschaft
vorgeworfenen Heinrich
P Punkt R Punkt ist bereits der Vollzug
der
Untersuchungshaft durch den
Ermittlungsrichter angeordnet worden
an der heutigen an den heutigen
Maßnahmen haben rund 3.000 Polizeibeamte
mitgewirkt
es waren eingesetzt polizeibeamte des
Bundes der Bundes des
Bundeskriminalamtes der Bundespolizei
sowie zahlreicher Landeskriminalämtern
und anderer Polizeidienststellen der
Bundesländer das zunächst einmal zum
Stand der Ermittlungen der Maßnahmen
heute vielen Dank
das also das Statement des
Generalbundesanwalts dr Peter Frank zu
den ersten Ermittlungen in der Razzia
von heute Morgen gegen 25 Personen aus
dem Reichsbürger Milieu wir sprechen
jetzt weiter mit Miro Dittrich
rechtsextremismusforscher von cemas
hättetrich das ist hier ein Tag der
Abgründe der Demokratie zeigt und ein
Tag bei dem vielen sicherlich nicht zum
Lachen und zum Schmunzeln zumute ist
aber ganz lieben Dank möchten wir an der
Stelle noch mal an Sie und Ihre Katze
von vorhin vor dem Statement ausrichten
zumindest ein kleines Signal von ein
bisschen schmunzel ein bisschen
Beruhigung von Ihrer Katze Grüße an die
Herr Dittrich bleiben wir aber bei den
harten Fakten und der Realität die uns
heute eingeholt hat vor dem Statement
des Generalbundesanwalts haben wir über
die Thematik gesprochen dass die Politik
die Szene der Reichsbürger die sich
entwickelt hat und auch die Personen die
auffällig geworden sind die heute
festgenommen werden sind Ihrer Meinung
nach zu lange hat wuchern lassen und
vielleicht auch unterschätzt hat
vielleicht greifen wir den Gedanken noch
mal auf und führen den von für den noch
mal aus
ja also ich finde es zeigt sich ja schon
es ist jetzt nicht der erste Fall dieses
Jahr sondern wir hatten bereits im
Frühling eine Verhaftung gegen eine
ähnliche Gruppe die hat ja diese
Ermittlungen hier jetzt erst losgestoßen
dort waren auch eine Ansammlung von
reichsbürgerinnen und anderen
verschwörungserzählungen die auch ein
Staatsstreich geplant hatten und ich
finde wenn jetzt in einem Jahr zwei
Gruppen haben die sich zum militanten
Mitteln entscheiden und meinen Status
vielleicht zu planen dann ist sie sehen
ja schon so weit gewachsen dass sich so
extreme ausgebildet haben lange Zeit
über die Pandemie ist die Reichweite
Bewegung sehr stark bewachsen es wurde
aber nur relativ wenig dagegen gemacht
auf der Straße wurden die rechtsgröße
toleriert und im digitalen Bereich gab
es auch sehr wenig verfolgungs- Leute
konnten dort ähm äußern dass sie sich
ein Nürnberg 2.0 Wünschen für
verantwortliche auch kurz vor der
Verhaftung hat einer der heute
verhafteten genauso ist solche
Äußerungen auf Telegramm verkündet und
ich finde es zeigt schon sehr deutlich
dass sie zu wenig gemacht wurde
[Musik]
wie beobachten sie eigentlich die
Entwicklung dass das jetzt auch von
Personen aus der sogenannten Mitte der
Gesellschaft unter anderem von Richterin
malzag Winkelmann auch ehemalige
afd-bundestagsabgeordnete dass diese
Aktionen auch von Personen die der
vermeintlichen Mitte der Gesellschaft
zuzuordnen sind jetzt in so radikale
Pläne umschwenken können was sehen sie
da für eine Entwicklung dieser Szene und
dieser Pläne
ich glaube das zeigt auch den Fehler
dass sehr lange solche
menschenfeindliche Positionen nur am
Rand der Gesellschaft gesucht wurde und
keine wirklich Auseinandersetzung
stattgefunden hat die verbreitet diese
Position doch eigentlich sind jetzt
kommt auf einmal die große Überraschung
darüber dass es doch in anderen Orten
sind was wir aber schon erleben ist dass
durch die Pandemie sehr viele Leute noch
mal mehr so verschwörungsideologische
Welten getrieben sind und sich dort im
digitalen Bereich vernetzt haben wissen
von der Forschung dass eine
Radikalisierung im Bereich
verschwörungserzählungen oft schneller
stattfindet als in anderen weil die
Leute das Gefühl haben sie würden auf
der richtigen Seite stehen und ein
gewisser Handlungsdruck entsteht
vielen Dank dass Sie das sozusagen auch
aus der forschungsschicht einordnen
gehen wir jetzt noch mal auch auf die
konkreten Pläne vielleicht für die die
jetzt auch dazu kommen der
Generalbundesanwalt dr Peter frank hat
sich geäußert haben wir gerade gehört
das gemeinsame Statement und die Pläne
zum Umsturz des deutschen Staates Design
laut ihm sehr konkret gewesen es habe
sogar Hinweise darauf gegeben dass die
Vereinigung geplant hat den Bundestag zu
stürmen vielleicht fassen wir Herr
Dietrich noch mal zusammen was Herr
Frank gesagt hat über die konkreten
Pläne was die Vereinigung vorhatte
als war eine Ansammlung von
verschiedenen
reichsbürgerinnenbewegung die einen
Staatsstreich geplant haben soll dafür
war eine Idee dass sie den
bundestagsstürmer
einen den Zugang darüber soll eine
ehemalige Bundestagsabgeordnete da der
AFD Ihnen dabei verschaffen dann weiter
war der Plan dass man eine militärische
Übergangsregierung Bilde und dann laut
die ist in der reichsbürgerung passt mit
den Alliierten mit den Siegermächten des
Zweiten Weltkriegs über weitere weiter
verhandeln solle dazu gab es mehrere
Treffen sie haben auf hatten Kontakte
zur Polizei zur Bundeswehr und in die
Justiz und es soll auch schon Übungen
geben sein dazu sollen auch Waffen
gekauft worden sein
Herr Dietrich eine abschließende Frage
aus ihrer Sicht wir sehen auf der einen
Seite heute die Abgründe die sich auch
in unserer Demokratie auftun können wir
sehen auf der anderen Seite aber auch
jetzt an dem heutigen Tag an dem
heutigen Morgen die erfolgreiche Arbeit
von Polizei und Rechtsstaat gemeinsam so
zumindest bei der Bekämpfung und bei der
Verhaftung was sagte dieser Tag heute
für Sie über unsere Demokratie über
unsere Gesellschaft aus und was muss
passieren dass im Vorfeld schon viel
viel mehr Präventionsarbeit geleistet
wird dass so etwas gar nicht erst
entsteht
bin froh dass im Laufe der Pandemie der
Verfolgungsdruck irgendwann mal doch so
groß geworden ist dass hier ermittelt
wird und solche Taten zumindest hindert
werden aber ich finde in einer
Demokratie sollte es erst gar nicht so
weit kommen dass wir in einem Jahr zwei
Pläne aus der reichsbürgerbewegung haben
ein staatsfrei durchzuführen und ich
finde hier wäre es wichtig dass man
wirklich diesen verschwörungsideologen
digital auch zuhört und sie ernst nimmt
in dem was sie sagen wenn sie davon
sprechen ist gebe eine allmächtige
Verschwörung von außen die bedrohe dass
Politik und Medien nur gesteuert werden
von dieser Verschwörung wenn Sie die
Angst haben dass etwa über die Impfungen
die deutschen ausgerottet werden sollen
und wenn diese Bewegung eigentlich keine
Möglichkeit gibt auf legitime
Möglichkeit sein politischen Willen
auszudrücken dann ist ja klar dass diese
Leute die Angst vor einem dämonischen
Feind haben dann irgendwann mal
entscheiden dass Gewalt das legitimeter
ist und hier ähm erlebt man vielleicht
die Demonstrationen der
verschwörungsideologischen Szene ist
zurückgehen und hat das Gefühl hier ist
etwas Wind aus der Bewegung raus das
macht sie aber eigentlich umso
gefährlicher weil die Leute eben noch
weniger denken das ist eine politische
Lösung für sie gibt sondern dass eben
jetzt genau die radikalen Leute die sich
verschärft haben in ihren Positionen
denken jetzt müsste das gewaltsam gelöst
werden
sagt Miro Dietrich hier bei uns bei ZDF
heute live ganz herzlichen Dank für ihre
Analysen und Einordnungen er ist
Rechtsextremismus Experte und Forscher
bei Zimmers vielen Dank
wir können jetzt noch mal schalten zu
unserer ZDF Rechtsexpertin sarattacke
sie war auch beim Statement des
Generalbundesanwalts dabei hallo Sarah
schön dass du wieder bei uns bist
wir haben das gemeinsame Statements wir
haben das Statement gesehen welchen
Eindruck welche Stimmung hat Herr Frank
da sozusagen neben den harten Fakten
verbreitet oder was ist auch daneben
euch noch bekannt geworden über die
ersten Ermittlungsergebnisse
der Generalbundesanwalt hat die
Gelegenheit genutzt noch mal ganz klar
zu formulieren wie sie hier vorgegangen
sind
er hat noch mal bestätigt dass es
weitreichende umfassende Festnahmen
heute gab und auch dass die Festgenommen
in dem Ermittlungsrichter vorgeführt
wurden allerdings waren keine Fragen
zugelassen das ist ungewöhnlich denn in
der Regel kann man bei einem bei einer
Pressekonferenz nochmal nachfragen aber
das zeigt die Ermittlungsbehörden und
auch der federführende
Generalbundesanwalt will aktuell über
das was sie und das ist ja doch auch
sehr detailreich der Öffentlichkeit
sagen keine weiteren Fragen beantworten
das heißt weiterhin ist offen wie sind
Sie auf das Netzwerk gestoßen sie sollen
es in etwa ein Jahr lang beobachtet
haben
es soll deutschlandweit verletzt gewesen
sein aber eben auch in
Sicherheitsbehörden wie der Mittel auf
sie aufmerksam geworden sind was jetzt
auch ob es weitere Mut Jugendliche
Mitwisser Unterstützer gibt ob das
Netzwerk noch größer ist als wir es
jetzt sehen all das wurde hier nicht
beantwortet der Generalbundesanwalt hat
nur die Tatsachen und Fakten genannt die
heute morgen per Pressemitteilung
sowieso schon öffentlich gemacht worden
das heißt der Generalbundesanwalt und
auch den mittelsbehörden sind sehr
vorsichtig und überlegen sehr gut welche
Informationen Sie der Öffentlichkeit
geben man muss sagen zu der groß
angelegten Aktion heute morgen zu den
Durchsuchungen die ist auffallend gut
dokumentiert das ZDF war früh vor Ort
bei einer Festnahme in Berlin aber auch
sehr viele andere Medien Printmedien
andere
TV Journalisten waren bei diversen
durchsuchen und Festnahmen dabei das
heißt die Sicherheitsbehörden hatten
offensichtlich auch ein hohes Interesse
dass diese Aktion diese groß angelegte
Aktion in der Öffentlichkeit sehr gut
dokumentiert wird sehr gut wahrgenommen
wird ich gehe davon aus dass die
Sicherheitsbehörden und die Ermittler
auch diesen Tag und die Festnahmen
nutzen wollten um zu zeigen wir sind wir
sehr Haft wir sind wachsam und wir
bemerken auch ein solche
also Terrorzelle rechtzeitig und haben
deshalb diese Aktion gemacht zu dem
Punkt Sarah können wir uns auch noch mal
den den Tweet auf der anderen Seite von
Stefan Niggemeier anschauen er spricht
davon dass die Dokumentation aus
lesersicht aus Zuschauersicht für ihn
praktisch sei aber für den
Fahndungserfolg vielleicht ja doch
problematisch da hatten wir auch gerade
die Einordnung von Herrn Dietrich dazu
er hat auch weiter Tweets noch geteilt
die die zeigen sollen dass die hat sehr
seit mindestens einer Woche ein offenes
Geheimnis sein soll das vielleicht nur
als Anregung auch zu dem Punkt Sarah
eine Frage von einem weiteren User bei
Facebook kommt sie rein von Sven
Odendahl er fragt wenn es diese
umstürzpläne die herr Frank ja auch
gerade noch bestätigt gab wie war die
Vernetzung in noch aktive Kreise der
Bundeswehr gibt es darüber gesicherte
Informationen
da gibt es aktuell zumindest soweit ich
weiß keine weiteren gesicherten
Informationen
man geht davon aus es soll ja eine
aktiver Soldat des der KSK dabei gewesen
sein der aber auch dort gemeldet wurde
bekannt war dass es dort keine weiteren
Entwicklung gibt aber auch das war zu
hören und zu lesen es sollen Polizisten
und Soldaten aktiv angeworben worden
sein ich gehe davon aus dass die
Ermittler die ja ein Jahr lang diese
mutmaßlichen Terroristen dieses
mutmaßliche Terror Netzwerk beobachtet
haben dass sie in dem Zeitraum sehr
genau ermittelt haben wer alles zu
diesem Netzwerk gehört wer auch
angesprochen wurde wer darauf auch
angesprungen ist und dass sie wirklich
den Kern des Netzwerks heute
festgenommen haben und da sie
offensichtlich so enge Ermittlung
geführt haben gehe ich aktuell nicht
davon dass es weitere Überraschungen
gibt aber natürlich ist genau das jetzt
angezeigt zu hinterfragen zu ermitteln
inwieweit aktive Polizisten aktive
Bundeswehrsoldaten aktive Richter
Menschen in der Justiz auch involviert
sind angesprochen sind angesprungen sind
auf diese Umsturzpläne gehen wir
vielleicht noch mal auf zwei der Köpfe
der Vereinigung in dem reichsbäcker
Milieu ein Kopf das haben wir
rausgearbeitet soll der in Frankfurt
wohnhafte reichsbürgerprinz Heinrich
Reus sein Sarah wer steckt hinter diesem
selbst ernannten Prinzen
auch das ist von hier aus schwer zu
sagen der Generalbundesanwalt hat noch
nicht mal seinen vollen Namen genannt
hat das abgekürzt weil wir hier
natürlich immer noch im Bereich der
Ermittlungen sind aber der Haftbefehl
der beantragt war dem stadtgegeben
worden das heißt der besagte mutmaßliche
Kopf des ganzen sitzt hier aktuell in
Karlsruhe in Untersuchungshaft
es soll sich um sogenannte Reichsbürger
handeln das ist natürlich keine homogene
Gruppe sie sollen gemeinsam sich eine
neue Staatsform überlegt haben und der
Festgenommene ähm
Prinz der tatsächlich ein Prinz sein
soll und kein gekaufter Titel soweit ich
gehört habe der soll sich als künftige
Staatsoberhaupt gesehen haben das klingt
alles reichlich abstrust da aber die
mutmaßlichen Terroristen bereits
Schießübungen gemacht haben da sie
bereits bewaffnet gewesen sein sollen in
Teilen da sie bereits sehr konkrete
Pläne hatten wie es danach weitergehen
soll sind sie doch durchaus als
gefährlich einzuschätzen natürlich sind
wir weit von irgendeiner Form des
Staatsstreiches entfernt aber natürlich
ist auch dass von solchen Menschen die
von
Verschwörungstheorien besessen sind die
sich in der eigenen Welt in einem
eigenen Konstrukt bewegen besondere
Gefahren ausgehen selbst wenn sie
natürlich keinen Umsturz herbeiführen
sollen sie bereit gewesen sein zu töten
und allein das zeigt dass
Terroranschläge möglich gewesen wären
auch die Ex
afd-bundestagsabgeordnete Mahlzeit
Winkelmann sie sei als Justizministerin
vorgesehen worden sie ist aktuell auch
weiterhin noch als Richterin aktiv
abschließende Frage Sarah vielleicht an
Dich was ist darüber bekannt wie es
jetzt in den nächsten Tagen in Sachen
Ermittlungen oder auch Wochen und
Monaten weitergehen wird was kannst du
uns darüber schon sagen
bekannt ist da noch nichts aus der Ferne
kann ich nur mutmaßen das natürlich die
Festgenommenen jetzt befragt werden
natürlich werden die sicherlich sich
auch Anwälte nehmen vielleicht auch von
ihrem Aussage Verweigerungsrecht
Gebrauch machen
sicher kann ich sagen dass bei den
Festnahmen natürlich auch sehr ja
umfassend sehr akribisch durchsucht
wurde ich weiß von der Festnahme in
Berlin von der
amtierenden Richterin dass dort
einige Kisten rausgetragen wurden aus
ihrer Wohnung das auch zusätzlich
Techniker spezielle Techniker
hinzugezogen wurden das heißt man kann
davon ausgehen dass umfassend Beweise
gesichert wurden die vielleicht auch
Aufschluss über die Frage die viele
umtreib geben inwieweit noch weitere
mutmaßliche Terroristen zu diesem
Netzwerk zählen und inwieweit ist auch
ähm ja ähm gefährlichen Arm in die
Bundeswehr in der Polizei in die Justiz
in die Sicherheitsbehörden gibt
sagt ZDF Rechtsexpertin vielen Dank für
deine Zeit über die ersten gesicherten
Informationen zu der großangelegten
ratja heute morgen
wir hoffen dass wir euch über die diese
Ratze über eine der größten in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik gesichert
informieren konnten etwa 3000
Spezialkräfte haben heute morgen 25
Personen aus dem reichsbürgermilieu
festgenommen und sie wegen
Terrorverdachts festgenommen sie wollten
den Bundestag stürmen und sie wollten
den deutschen Staat durch eine eigene
Staatsform ersetzen vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen und wenn ihr weiter informiert
bleiben wollt über dieses Thema schaut
gerne auch in unsere Social Media Kanäle
oder in unserer App ZDF heute oder auch
im ZDF Fernsehprogramm macht's gut bis
zum nächsten mal hier bei ZDF heute live
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen tschüss